midians metro-system is modern and
efficient the first line opened in 1995
these young people are visiting from all
over South and Central America to attend
the conference of the global shapers
initiative they're interested in
learning about how Midian managed to
modernize and upgrade its infrastructure
the Metro links outlying neighborhoods
or community may no drug lords to the
city centre vigilant staff help keep the
public transit systems safe and clean
well Camille Lewis is one of the
organizers of this special sightseeing
trip this is the first time the annual
meeting of global shapers is being held
in his hometown they're going to visit
community neighborhood 13 built on a
steep hillside it was once a slum
notorious for squalor drugs crime and
brutal gangs
it is you know there are many things
that stay with you for life such as
losing family members friends and
neighbors in the conflict we had here by
myself lost an uncle a cousin and a
brother it's really rough community is
changing fast infrastructure investment
is helping to revive the district and
the entire city kids can play outside
without fearing for their lives we want
to make things better for society there
aren't just bad guys living in this
neighborhood killers and dealers there
are people who hold down jobs who work
as cooks actors or dancers they have a
perspective and prospects a way out of
the violence in 2011 escalators were
inaugurated that connect community with
a city below there's a drop of more than
380 meters from the top to the bottom
it's hard for outsiders to appreciate
how bad things used to be
okay try to imagine this without the
escalator or even proper steps just dirt
well that's how it was people often had
to carry their children on their backs
to get to their homes up there on the
hillside
yotaka notice on video feeds to discuss
global shapers learn from each other
aim is to help drive social change and
innovation but not all activities are
socially oriented or deal with urban
planning the conference is being held
downtown the participants come from all
walks of life law business the arts they
want to promote access to education and
modern technology for all Latin America
is the most unequal region in the world
the municipality is continuing to invest
in community and the local global
shapers want to contribute to the
transformation of their city everyone
keeps saying young people are the
problem and not the solution we have to
realize that we are in fact the solution
and on top of that we always see
ourselves as the future but we should
actually see ourselves as the president
I think modeun has undergone an
astounding turnaround from the most
dangerous city on earth to one that is
more peaceful more livable and more
prosperous but there is still a long way
to go
you